[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo on va refaire toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
en 30 minutes
bonjour catllar bonjour michael et
aujourd'hui nous accueillons patrick
kanner bonjourbonjour vient ministre de
la ville de la jeunesse et des sports et
vous êtes désormais sénateur socialiste
du nord
eh bien il ya trois thèmes qu'on va
commenter cette semaine avec vous la
première partie du budget 2010 8 adopté
en commission des finances
isf réforme est ainsi que la taxe
d'habitation les yachts et les voitures
de course taxer un dernier vote des
députés sur le projet de loi
antiterroriste il prendra le relais de
l'état d'urgence et puis le dossier
alsthom le pdg du groupe étaient devant
députés et sénateurs pour évoquer la
fusion avec siemens ricaneurs six tables
dossier qui vous intéresse on va
commencer que le budget oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les députés ont planché pendant
presque 20 heures sur la première partie
de ce budget au menu bien évidemment lié
sf la taxe d'habitation
voici le résumé proposé par habib cas
c'est la mesure la plus controversée de
ce projet de loi de finances la
transformation de l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune en impôts sur la fortune
immobilière
le gouvernement entend favoriser
l'investissement
nous avons effectivement aussi envie de
faire en sorte de rapatrier un certain
nombre d'exilés fiscaux autant
continuant à faire en sorte que le
patrimoine immobilier dont le patrimoine
immobilier soit un patrimoine qui lui
continue à être taxés parce que c'est un
patrimoine qui n'est pas un patrimoine
que l'on peut convertir je dirais dans
l'économie réelle et le financement de
nos entreprises cette nouvelle taxation
ne prend plus en compte les valeurs
mobilières et les placements
la gauche dénonce un cadeau fait aux
riches et c'est pas en supprimant lisf
que l'on va lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale et qu'on va rapatrier les
capitaux
ça c'est faux l' isf malgré tout ce que
vous dites va bénéficier aux plus
grosses fortunes de france et dans
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
vous oubliez le mot solidarité sous le
feu des critiques
la majorité a tenté d'amender certaines
mesures par exemple les bateaux de plus
de 30 mètres seront désormais taxées la
mesure est jugée contre productive par
les républicains moi j'avais cru qu on
s'inscrivait dans une politique
d'attractivité du pays une politique
d'offres ce type de signaux vous paraît
peut-être dérisoire mais ce sont des
signaux d'une importance extrême sur les
flux économiques
autre mesure polémique adopté en
commission la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour 80% des ménages
le gouvernement entend donner un coup de
pouce aux classes moyennes et populaires
mais de leur côté certains élus sont
inquiets car cet impôt finance une
grande partie des services publics des
collectivités territoriales on touche là
aussi la question du financement des
collectivités argentan bien il ya 10
milliards du milliard d'euros c'est
énorme c'est un tiers des ressources et
j'ai bien compris qu'on nous explique
que ça sera compensée mais moi les
compensations à un moment donné a
annoncé de ce type là je
doute qu'il soit forcément pérenne
l'article a finalement été adopté cette
suppression se fera sur trois ans et
représentera un coût de 10 milliards
d'euros pour l'état
le texte sera débattu en séance publique
le 17 octobre prochain et on imagine que
dans l'hémicycle il va y avoir débat
encore est ce qu est ce qui me
caractérise pour vous le plus peut-être
ce budget est ce qu'il symbolise la
politique d' emmanuel macron vous
rappeler ce qu'on disait du bouclier
fiscal de nicolas sarkozy moi je
parlerais plus au delà de confusion
fiscale pas de confiscation et de
confusion fiscale
je trouve vraiment qu'on ne voit pas de
lisibilité dans ce dans ce budget quel
est son véritable équilibre aujourd'hui
avec les sf qui est l'exemple peut-être
le plus tô t need you me permettez
l'expression
on se retrouve devant une situation tout
à fait extraordinaire je voudrais
prendre un exemple très concret
un citoyen qui a huit cent mille euros
de biens immobiliers et qui a trois
millions d'euros de biens en actifs
actions placements divers payer avec l'
isf 21000 euros d'impôts avec le nouveau
système ne prenne paiera plus rien
trouvez vous ça normal moi non alors on
peut me dire oui mais ça fera revenir
les exilés fiscaux ne voudrais pas filer
droite et de gauche ce budget c'est un
budget aujourd'hui qui manifestement
serre n'ont pas les riches mais les très
très riches je reprends l'expression de
mon ancien collègue michel sapin s'est
vraiment ceux qui sont le plus au plus
haut niveau de revenus qui seront
concernés et il ignore manifestement
ceux qui ont le plus besoin de la
solidarité nationale et du jour nous
pourrons y revenir sur différents alors
justement dans ce budget il ya la
suppression pour 80% des ménages de la
taxe d'habitation ce satan peau qui
repose sur des bases des années 70 alors
ça veut dire que 20 % des gens ne la
paierons oui et c'est le sacré pour vous
une inégalité de fait entre les 80 % qui
seront exonérés et les autres la taxe
professionnelle est un impôt idiot
rappelé bouscule jacques chirac la taxe
d'habitation de l'impôt profondément
injuste non révisés depuis 1970
donc il fallait non pas le supprimer
pour 80% mais pour cent pour cent de le
consensus sacré investissement
bien sûr et parce que les 20% qui vont
continuer à le payer vont regarder ceux
qui ne payent plus en 10 ans mais moi
j'ai le droit à accéder au crès j'ai le
droit axelera cantines scolaires plus
que toi parce que tu ne payes revient au
financement des services publics de la
commune donc moi je préférerais qu'on
supprime totalement la taxe d'habitation
et qu'on rebaptise un impôt plus juste
juste si c'est possible c'est naturel
nous voilà un nouvel impôt de recettes
fiscales pour les collectivités sauf à
dire que les doigts si j'en avais déjà
une idée en tête
syfy si oui de partir sur l'arrêté est
revenu des gens la taxe dotations ne
repose pas sur le revenu et bien partant
sur un impôt local basé sur le revenu
des personnes et alors là tout le monde
sera d'accord
donc aujourd'hui on afin de créer une
usine à gaz et sans pour autant dire
exactement comment se fera la
compensation pour les communes si on
comprend bien au sénat vous ne voterait
pas ce texte tel qu'est en l'état en
tous cas vous ne voterez pas savez au
sénat nous avons une double opposition
et l'eau et l'air en tout cas la
majorité l hérault sénat et nous sommes
dans l'opposition et nous serons
extrêmement inquiet ça devient très
compliqué mais peut-être que c'est parce
que c'est compliqué qu'il nous faudra
être imaginatif et faire des
propositions dans le budget 2010 8 c'est
la politique de la ville ils sont
logement ce que c'est l'agrandissement
des ministres en charge il n'y a plus de
minutes de la ville
c'est une première depuis 40 ans depuis
la création de ce ministère de la
cohésion des territoires qui reprend une
partie du territoire qui est aussi le
ministère du logement de l'urbanisme de
l'aménagement des territoires de la
ville c'est trois ou quatre ministères
sur une seule c'était une erreur d'avoir
éclaté ce portefaix que vous aviez à
l'époque moi je considère que la
politique de la ville représente
aujourd'hui 1500 quartier et six
millions d'habitants et il fallait une
incarnation politique pour porter cette
cette politique à partir de là les
crédits ont été rabotées en 2017 il
serait maintenue en 2018 2019 2020
tant mieux mais par contre la baisse de
l'apl de 5 euros déjà dès le 1er octobre
de 60 euros
dans les années suivantes va plus
d'avoir fragilisé populations les plus
pauvres qui vivent dans un logement
social et surtout la mesure qui consiste
à dire aux bailleurs sociaux et bien
diminuer vos loyers
or les empêcher d'investir dans ces
quartiers donc c'est une double peine
qu'on est en train de mettre en oeuvre
en quelques secondes
ça fait dire à jean louis borloo ça lui
rappelle 2003 2004 c'est en 2005 qu'il y
avait eu des émeutes dans les quartiers
et qu'il avait senti se vend dans les
quartiers est ce que vous diriez la même
chose aujourd'hui qu'on est peut-être à
la veille des meutes écoutez je ne
souhaite sauver les émeutes
vous savez j'ai des goûts d'un
gouvernement de biya le lui les autres
sentiments mon sentiment c'est qu'il y a
une forme de désespoir
aujourd'hui dans ces quartiers en disant
mais on nous oublie nous n'avons plus
d'interlocuteur le monde associatif est
pénalisé par la baisse des contrats
aidés
voire même la disparition dans un cas
des contrats aidés donc tout ceci cumulé
peut créer un film un phénomène de
colère et la colère peut aboutir à autre
chose je ne le souhaite pas qu'il j'en
parle de malentendu
alors patrick kanner deuxième focus de
la semaine la loi antiterroriste qui a
été votée à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les députés ont donc voté le texte
élaboré en commun avec les sénateurs en
début de semaine la nouvelle loi inscrit
dans le droit certaine mesure
d'exception qui étaient mises en oeuvre
pendant l'état d'urgence explications de
flora sauvage pour trouver un accord
avec le sénat sur le projet de loi
antiterroriste les députés ont cédé sur
les points les plus sensibles alors y
ait eu quelques points qui ont été
discutés notamment par exemple les
abords immédiats des périmètres de
protection
la notion d'idées ou de théorie dans le
cadre des fermetures de lieux de culte
mais d'un point de vue général néanmoins
nous avons réussi à nous mettre d'accord
première ligne rouge pour les sénateurs
l'obligation de déclarer tous les
identifiants de moyens de communication
électroniques en commission mixte
paritaire
cette disposition a été supprimée à
cause du risque d'inconstitutionnalité
autre cheval de bataille de la chambre
haute le périmètre au sein duquel il
sera possible d'exécuter des contrôles
d'identité frontaliers le gouvernement
l'avait fixé à 20 km autour des points
de passage extérieurs
il sera finalement de 10 kilomètres
comme le souhaitaient les sénateurs
quand on modifier le code pénal dans la
durée on ne peut pas accepter des
mesures trop restrictives pour les
libertés et par conséquent il faut
qu'elle soit temporaire donc nous avons
étendu ce que nous avons appelée la
clause d'autodestruction que le sénat
avait inventé au mois de juillet à
toutes les mesures restrictives de
liberté
enfin sur les assignations à résidence
c'est la version du sénat qui a été
retenu là où les députés souhaitaient un
pointage quotidien au commissariat le
texte de la commission mixte paritaire
revient à un pointage 3 fois par semaine
les il ya un point sur lequel les
députés n'ont pas plié l'appel un juge
des libertés et de la détention en cas
de perquisition les sénateurs voulaient
rendre obligatoire l'obtention de
l'accord du juge
lorsque les personnes perquisitionnées
était retenu sur place
patrick kanner vous êtes fait partie de
la commission des lois au sénat alors
donc ce texte élaboré en commun a été
voté par les députés vous devez à votre
tour le voter le 18 octobre
il semblerait que les députés de la
majorité elle ré mais lâcher un peu de
lest pour permettre aux sénateurs
d'apporter leurs marques
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ce
qu'il ya des marges de manoeuvre
jes des sénateurs qui l'emportent sur la
foule des députés ils ont rétabli le
pratiquer les deux donc oui il ya des
améliorations qui ont été évoqués donc
votre excellent reportage simplement
fondamentalement c'est l'intégration de
l'état d'urgence dans le droit commun le
6 juillet dernier on avait voté on avait
adopté le principe de la reconduction
puis jusqu'au 1er novembre de l'état
d'urgence moi je suis à titre personnel
réservé sur le fait qu'une situation un
caractère exceptionnel de vienne du
droit commun même si tout cela
s'arrêtera où s'arrêterait ans le 31
décembre 2010 ce qui vous fait peur qu
est ce qui vous inquiète
vous savez l'assignation à résidence
même si elle devient une assignation sur
un territoire communal reste pour moi
une mise en cause de la liberté
individuelle mais je mesure que dans
cette période ils ont besoin de deux
sujets qui permettent de rassembler
compris les français pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
donc je comprends bien la période qui
est qui est la nôtre simplement nous
transformons l'état d'urgence que j'ai
voté en tant que membre du gouvernement
dès le 15 novembre 2015 à minuit je me
souviens très bien de ce conseil des
ministres on transforme ta d'urgence en
situation de droit commun et là nous
sommes réservés n'est pas sortir de
l'état d'urgence moi je pense que l'état
d'urgence permet un contrôle
parlementaire extrêmement précis
aujourd'hui ça devient la loi
il ya eu des améliorations dont acte et
c'est pour cela que selon toute
vraisemblance le groupe socialiste et
républicain ne votera pas ce texte mais
ne votera pas non plus contre et donc il
ya une intention qui est potentiel n'est
pas à venir une abstention
potentiellement à venir mais pendant
l'état d'urgence la mise en oeuvre d'
état d'urgence les parlementaires
sénateurs et députés exercer un contrôle
sur l'application des tas de gens se
sera pas le cas demain avec la nouvelle
loi sera moins le cas puisque c'est la
loi fait devient la loi et avec une loi
qui donne plus de pouvoir à l'exécutif
au pouvoir administratif
le juge n'a pas été totalement
réintégrer cela a été dit aussi dans
votre reportage donc il faudra beaucoup
beaucoup de vigilance des parlementaires
et moi je suis favorable à ce qu'il y
ait une forme de commissions pour le
suivi de cette loi de manière à ce que
les libertés individuelles ne doivent
jamais être mise en cause y compris en
période de demande et donc une forme de
contrôle de la loi qui sera votée
prochainement même si votre combat
s'abstenir cette commission vous voulez
en prendre la tête
on va coûter en tout cas si je peux en
être initiateur en tout cas de oui le
touquet les socialistes les socialistes
ces sénateurs républicains serons
extrêmement vigilants
notre abstention n'est pas une
abstention d'opposition systématique une
abstention de vigilance et que j'allais
vous demandez pas ce que au regard des
français aujourd'hui au regard du
contexte évidemment dans lequel nous
vivons est ce que les français
pourraient comprendre que vous vous
abstenez on va l'expliquer on va
l'expliquer on va expliquer aux français
que l'état de droit est une formidable
sécurité finalement contre toute dérive
d'un exécutif qui abuseraient de ses
pouvoirs donc ce n'est pas sérieuse il
n'y a pas un abus de pouvoir
je ne puis je n'ai pas dit cela agit
simplement que l'état d'urgence est un
outil exceptionnel très contrôlée par le
parlement ici nous rentrons dans le
droit commun ce qui risque d'affaiblir
ce contrôle est donc à nous trouver les
voies et moyens y compris par des outils
à
évidemment dans le nord de la france
6 d'alstom et le patron d'alstom est
venu devant les députés et devant les
sénateurs
à quelques heures d'intervalle il a
martelé son message la fusion avec le
groupe allemand siemens n'entraînera pas
de fermetures de sites
nous savons que toute fusion est
anxiogène et nous savons que toute
fusion peut donner lieu à des
spéculations sur quelles vont être les
restructurations quelles vont être les
les nouvelles organisations qu'est ce
qui va être privilégié et c est donc
nous avons nous voulu dire aux
différents sites
écoutez nous prenons l'engagement de ne
pas fermer de site pendant pendant les
quatre prochaines années
oui j'allais dire il ya une préparation
de tous les sites pendant quatre ans et
oui je pense que cette opération va les
renforcer
mécaniquement parce que le groupe sera
plus fort et donc pourra conquérir plus
de marché alors devant les sénateurs il
a redit claque te ment mot pour mot ce
qui venait de dire devant les députés
est ce que vous croyez monsieur
poupart-lafarge je n'ai pas de raison de
ne pas le croire
à ce stade vous avez vu le délai il
avance une quatre ans pas de fermeture
prendre en quatre ans nous allons
récupérer des marchés notamment par
rapport à nos concurrents chinois
puisque c'est bien de cela dont il
s'agit et nous serons capables grâce à
ce nouveau groupe de pouvoir mieux
offrir en fait des réponses aux appels
d'offres qui seront lancés par les
pouvoirs publics qu'ils soient nationaux
ou internationaux dont acte moi je ne
fais pas le procès d'intention
je suis favorable à titre personnel à ce
qu'il y ait des grands groupes européens
à condition naturellement que l'emploi
soit préservée et que la modernisation
soit assurée ce colloque est la question
c'est aussi que l'investissement continu
vous avez raison de rappeler que dans le
nord alstom ça veut dire quelque chose
et notamment dans le sud de notre
valenciennes vous allez être vigilant
quand même vous avez quelques
inquiétudes par rapport à ce qui suit je
suis je suis sénateur non pas de l'île
monsieur je suis lillois mais sénateur
du nord lors n'at il donc ma compétence
territoriale c'est tout le département
et le rôle je crois d'un parlementaire
c'est d'avoir ce non pas cette idée de
contrôle mais tout cas moi je
demanderais des rendez vous
demandera des rendez vous aux dirigeants
locaux par l'entrée n'a pas un pouvoir
hiérarchique et heureusement sur un chef
d'entreprise
par contre cachaine entreprises sachent
que les politiques au sens large du
terme s'intéresse à la vie économique je
crois que oui mais il peut faire des
visites comme ami peut il peut aller sur
place rencontrer les gens discuter
rencontrer aussi rencontré les patrons
mais aussi rencontrer les syndicats je
crois que ce sera mon rôle en tant que
tel alstom c'est là aussi un totem dans
le département du nord comme d'autres
grandes industries et donc les sénateurs
et là toutes sensibilités confondues
seront extrêmement sensible savez taux
de chômage dans le nord est tellement
important qu'il est là qu'il crée
aujourd'hui les phénomènes populiste
qu'il soit à gauche ou à droite et donc
pour nous la préservation de l'emploi et
la création d'emplois nouveaux qualifiés
est un enjeu majeur vous parliez de
cette idée de contrôle c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant aussi de vous entendre
là dessus est ce que vous pourriez
demander au ministre l'économie à venir
s'expliquer dans quelques mois pour voir
où on en est oh nous le maire devant les
sénateurs pour s'expliquer là nous avons
des commissions permanentes qui peuvent
inviter tous les ministres est convoqué
il y avait moi quand j'étais ministre
chaque fois qu'une commission permanente
me demander d'intervenir ce traité le
sujet je le faisais c'est le sait
l'équilibré normal des pouvoirs dans la
cinquième au lit alors prenez le vin est
venu à l'assemblée il a dit notamment
qu'il n'y avait pas d'inquiétude puisque
il piloterait notamment le comité de
suivi de la fusion est ce que c'est une
garantie suffisante pour vous encore une
fois pourquoi voulez vous que je mette
en doute l'engagement d'un ministre moi
j'en prends acte je dis simplement que
c'est à usage est donc dans l'action que
nous verrons si ces engagements peuvent
être tenus là sur pièce on va
décortiquer maintenant patrick kanner
votre actualité un petit peu plus
politiques ainsi que les petits le petit
tumulte de la semaine avec jim jarrassé
s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
patrick kanner on va parler un peu de
vous et vos rapports avec ceux avec qui
vous avez gouverner lors du procès
précédent quinquennat et le premier
d'entre eux françois hollande vous
l'avez vu récemment françois hollande je
vais bientôt le voir vous allez bientôt
le voir il consulte beaucoup nous dit on
les anciens socialistes par les
socialistes
on sent qu'il veut encore jouer un rôle
dans la reconstruction de la gauche est
ce que vous trouvez ça bien
ça vous étonne non seulement on parle
voilà donc vous vous répondez comme moi
donc non le président de république
aulas n'a pas été battu aux élections
présidentielles ne s'est pas présenté il
a considéré qu'il n'était pas en
situation de à partir de là à dire qu'il
peut avoir un agenda politique pour le
futur sur un plan institutionnel
rien ne les oblige à rester en dehors de
la vie politique
certains vont dire oui mais c'est un peu
trop tôt je n'en sais rien trop tôt trop
tard en tout cas il consulte il sait une
chose c'est que le parti socialiste est
aujourd'hui une situation extrêmement
dramatique je pèse mes mots
nous ne sommes pas au fond de la piscine
nous sommes quasiment dans le siphon et
que s'il n'y a pas un rebond majeur dans
les mois qui viennent eh bien nous
risquons l'extinction pour moi
simplement des ce que nous représentons
c'est à dire une social démocratie
monsieur maquereau a choisi ses
opposants d'un côté potentiellement
monsieur wauquiez jeudi à
potentiellement sont les choses se faire
de l'autre
jean luc mélenchon et lui occuper
l'espace central eh bien nous nous
disons en tant que socialiste en tant
que j'ai démocrate assumer nous voulons
occuper le rebond le bord ont leurs bons
pardon il pourrait venir du prochain
patron du parti socialiste qui va être
désigné l'an prochain est ce que vous
avez un candidat en tête les socialistes
ne décideront alors de leur congrès il
ya des instances pour cela il y a
beaucoup de personnes capables de porter
ce flambeau mois chacun sait que je suis
proche de cette fine aux folles voilà je
ne m'en cache pas mais je vois aussi
fonctionner si tu es mal qui est le
coordonnateur aujourd'hui et de l'action
du soleil
françois hollande aura sûrement un
leader dans sa tête
simplement où nous devons choisir celui
ou celle parce qu'il ya aussi des femmes
qui sont en position de pouvoir prendre
cette sensualité celui ou celle qui sera
capable d'incarner ce renouveau cette
incarnation ne pas dire pour autant être
candidat en 2022 et vous quel rôle vous
voulez avoir là dedans est ce que vous
vous avez envie une envie santé l'esprit
d'être un petit peu le gardien du temple
de la de la hollande hic si on peut
appeler ça comme ça moi moi moi je dois
les revoir les uns les autres les
anciens ministres lundi soir avec pierre
mauroy et pierre mauroy avait un mot à
la bouche le rassemblement et je pense
que les socialistes ne s'en sortiront
qui s'ils sont capables de se rassembler
avant d'essayer de se diviser pour des
envies et des enjeux de pouvoir lui
paraît que vous voyez l'ancien ministre
wi'am en jeu leur téléphone j'ai prévu
des invités au sénat pour discuter ou il
est l'avenir ou en tout cas y compris de
la manière de valoriser même si encore
une fois on ne gagne pas une élection
une refondation s'ils ont un bilan mais
sachez que moi en tant que ministre
j'ai été profondément choqué meurtri de
ne pas pouvoir défendre le bilan qui
était le nôtre la revanche chaque année
c'est sûrement pas une revanche ce qui
est l'esprit de revanche ce n'est pas
productif
par contre qu'on n'oublie pas le passé
il ya des traces qui sont là et
j'aimerais que tu ne m'aimes pas
automatiquement dans les traces mais
qu'on n'efface pas on va parler de
manuel valls
avait téléphoné à manuel valls emana qui
dit on a été traité de nazi par jean luc
mélenchon oui jean luc mélenchon qui a
vu que ce n'était pas vrai a démenti il
a fait je n'étais pas là je n'ai pas
écouté
en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive moi j'ai
un profond respect une véritable
affection pour manuel valls vous l'aviez
soutenu lors de la primaire en chine je
lis lui je ne le regrette pas face à
benoît hamon qui a gagné mais dont on
connaît ensuite le résultat et le
parcours personnel que vous imaginez
quelle trajectoire pour l'ancien premier
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'il ait eu
beaucoup de mal finalement être se faire
élire dans son se faire élire dans son
fief de d'evry je vous ai parlé
d'affection je vais parler de profond
respect pour manuel valls mais par
contre je ne suis pas en phase avec lui
sur ses dernières déclarations sur la
manière dont il envisage son avenir
personnel et peut-être avec ce qui
l'entouré déclaration les gens quels
genres et stable aux gauchistes l'islamo
gauchisme non non pas par rapport
surtout au budget fac son soutien au
budget ces éléments majeurs on en a
parlé de pas même si on m'assure d'une
politique nationale et donc moi qui a
trahi son compte non je ne parle pas de
trahison
il est dans sa ligne voilà il va
jusqu'au bout de sa pensée il a soutenu
emmanuel macron en voilà en quittant la
responsabilité qui aurait dû être la
sienne peut-être en train étant candidat
aux élections primaires il n'a pas
soutenu benoît hamon dont acte
ça n'enlève rien encore une fois au
sentiment que je porte pour lui parce
que c'était un grand patron pour moi
mais je ne partage pas aujourd'hui sa
ligne politique ici on parle un petit
peu de la politique dans le nord voilà
de martine aubry alors on sait que vous
relatez elles n'ont pas toujours été au
beau fixe
est-ce que vous avez marqué un point en
étant élu sénateur du nord là où par
exemple quelqu'un comme françois lamy
que l'on présente souvent comme le
dauphin de martine aubry pour la mairie
a été assez sèchement battu aux
législatives face à rémy a été battu
mais il n'a pas été le seul
ouais il n'y avait plus été en effet eu
l'idée il n'y a plus de députés
socialistes dans le nord sur les vingt
et une conception il n'ya plus détestés
liste il y a maintenant trois
parlementaires socialistes un député
européen gilles pargneaux et martine
filleul et moi comme celle où
oui j'ai des racines c'est vrai que je
suis un dur à cuire il s'agit est-ce que
les municipales 2020 voilà vous y pensez
le matin moi je n'ai qu'une seule
préoccupation est d'ailleurs martine
aubry a dit exactement la même chose
c'est que le beffroi ne bascule pas à
droite
aujourd'hui le jocondien il est froid et
fragilisé un risque réel et fragilisé
avait il n'y a plus de parlementaires
socialistes députés sur l'île nous avons
deux députés insoumis des députés en
marche
voilà nous sommes un peu dans le rang
par pierre mauroy mais cette expression
c'est à ces images et là il faut savoir
se battre sur le donjon
je pense que nous sommes en phase 2 à
nous de nous rassembler et martine aubry
naturellement et maire de lille elle
devra prendre
elle prendra ses restes à laura la
priorité martine aubry maire de lille
donc je pendant trois ans voire quatre
ans il ya un report d'élections
municipales
moi je considère que ma claque ça vous
intéresse je ne sais pas sous quelle
forme cela m'intéresse mais ce que je
sais c'est que je prendrai toute ma part
d'une manière ou d'une autre pour que ce
beffroi reste sociale des mortels et si
jamais vous deviez si si les conditions
sont réunies nous en reparlerons pour
l'instant je n'ai pas évoqué cette
dernière montre avec martine aubry très
rapidement dernière petite question est
ce que votre départ du gouvernement vous
permet de vous consacrer un peu plus à
votre grande passion qui est l'opéra
vous avez plus de temps peut-être oui
jeu ce soir je vais assister au gala
mozart au théâtre des champs-elysées
paraît emmanuelle haïm grande chef
d'orchestre du nord
et comme j'adore le baroque ce sera
parfait et bien ce sera le mot de la
firme hertz patrick kanner d'avoir été
l'invité de parlons est loin terminait
justement sur ce petit air de carnon à
l'ehess prochaine
[Musique]